as far as Matt Hancock is concerned I do  believe there's quite a lot of people in  a building not too far away from here  the House of Commons and the House of  Lords who've downloaded a certain app so  they can vote I'm not sure if that's a  good thing is that right yeah yeah  that's a great story is that true yeah  of course it is wow that's amazing um so  you think that he should be here you  think it's totally inappropriate that an  MP should be the other side of the world  I mean I I've read this morning what he  said about why Harry wants to prove that  all you know all in MPS are human and  that's actually you know that is true  all MPS are human but  um I think we do that every day in our  constituencies and and what we do in  Parliament